أمر فلاديمير بوتين بإرسال القوات إلى
الأسواق العالمية في أوكرانيا أدى إلى
تراجع الأسواق الأوروبية بعد عمليات
بيع حادة في العقود الآجلة لآسيا ، كما أدت إلى تراجع
كبير مراسلة الأعمال في مجلس الشيوخ
كريستين رومان هنا مع إلقاء نظرة على
ما يمكن أن يحدث ولماذا العالم
حقاً في حالة توتر روماني ، نعم الروسية
القوات في حالة تحرك وكذلك
أسواق آسيا العالمية تغلق على انخفاض حاد في
أوروبا هنا ،
وستكون العقود الآجلة لمؤشر الأسهم هذه أول
فرصة لنا نحن المستثمرين للاستجابة
لعطلة نهاية أسبوع من تفاقم
العناوين الرئيسية في روسيا ، أدى هوس بوتين بأوكرانيا
إلى تراجع الأسهم الأسبوع الماضي  فقد مؤشر داو
جونز وحده أكثر من 650 نقطة
الأسبوع الماضي ، أي ما يقرب من 2 في المائة ، وكان
رد الفعل الكبير في أسواق
النفط ، قفزت أسعار النفط الخام الأمريكية أكثر من خمسة في
المائة بين عشية وضحاها.
النفط والغاز الطبيعي أي
انقطاع في الإمدادات من القتال أو من
العقوبات من شأنه أن يرفع الطاقة العالمية
الأسعار التي تعني تأثيرًا مباشرًا على
الولايات المتحدة أيضًا بالطبع أسعار الغاز المرتفعة وأسعار
العشب المرتفعة هنا بالفعل عند أعلى مستوى لها منذ
سبع سنوات والمتوسط الوطني أه
كثر من 300350 للغالون بزيادة 20 سن
ًا في الشهر الماضي ولكنها ليست فق
في  سيؤدي ضخ جميع تكاليف الطاقة إلى
ارتفاع كبير مثل وقود الطائرات الكهربائية للتدفئة المنزلية
وتكاليف النقل التجارية الأخرى
، وسيؤدي ذلك إلى
ارتفاع أسعار المستهلك بالكامل
مما يؤدي إلى ارتفاع التضخم إلى أعلى
مستوى خلال 40 عامًا ، ويقدر أحد التحليلات
أنه إذا وصل النفط الأمريكي إلى 110 دولارات.
يتوقع البرميل أن يصل معدل التضخم إلى أعلى 10 في
المائة مما يضغط على
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي لإجراء المزيد من
الزيادات الحادة في أسعار الفائدة لترويض هذا
التضخم الذي يرفع
تكاليف الاقتراض للجميع على قروض الرهن العقاري
وقروض السيارات وبطاقات الائتمان ، لذا فإن إصلاح
مشكلة التضخم يعني آخر
مشكلة ارتفاع تكاليف الاقتراض